foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP 4193
object class save
special containment procedures
all known instances of scp-4193 are to
be kept in a secure container at site-23
test subjects may only be administered
more than one dose of scp-4193 if due
for termination or if a long-term
humanoid containment cell is available
description
[Music]
scp-4193 is the group designation for a
supply of 32 blue pharmaceutical caplets
eight millimeters in diameter with the
Playboy Bunny embossed on one side
the first time in scp-4193 caplet is
ingested it acts as a combination of
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drug
NSAID of the propionic acid class and a
tryptin only with nearly instant effect
and no side effects other than slight
pupil dilation
scp-4193 relieves migraines cluster
headaches fever swelling and muscle
stiffness if the subject suffers from
chronic migraines intervals between
regular episodes will increase from 30
to 180 days
the second time a particular subject is
administered in scp-4193 caplet in
addition to the above effects the
subject's eyes including the skull's eye
sockets and all connective and nerve
tissue painlessly decrease in size by 50
percent over the course of half a second
after the metamorphic change the subject
is myopic nearsighted similar to some
cases of microthalmia and or nanothalmus
the subject acquires the anomalous
ability to focus on objects to a level
of detail approximately equivalent to
utilizing an optical microscope at 10
times magnification subjects describe
using this anomalous ability as like
zooming in with a camera
subsequently each time an scp-4193
caplet is ingested the subject's eyes
decrease in size by another 50 percent
the myopia becomes more acute and the
possible magnification increases tenfold
this process reaches a limit when a
subject's eyes are one millimeter in
diameter providing Vision that tests at
approximately 6 over 30 on the visual
Acuity scale and correlating with the
anomalous ability to focus on nearby
objects with the equivalent of roughly
10 000 times magnification however from
the third scp-4193 caplet onward
scp-4193 releases anywhere from 40 to
milligrams of MDMA into the subject's
bloodstream whenever taken while some
test subjects consistently received a
relatively safe amount of MDMA multiple
test subjects died from acute MDMA
toxicity following hypothermia
hyponatremia serotonin syndrome and
multiple organ failure for reaching the
limit of
scp-4193's anomalous effects test
subjects May report hallucinations after
taking an scp-4193 caplet on average
hallucinations started after the fourth
or fifth dose once experienced these
side effects never Abate and can be
divided into three categories of
hallucinations
some humans are seen as modal corpses
wet with Rod and extensively infested
with slow-moving worms or maggots the
worms are invariably described as
approximately 0.1 millimeters thick and
never described as longer than five
millimeters
some humans usually authority figures or
loved ones are perceived as human-shaped
swarms of insects swarm organisms are of
varying types and no individual insect
is ever described as longer than five
millimeters
subjects report minuscule humanoids 2 to
10 millimeters in height which attempt
to crawl into the orifices of living
humans especially the test subject
supplement 4193 1. discovery a bottle of
scp-4193 couplets was discovered while
examining the effects of a minor Person
of Interest Rhonda Clayton after her
reported death on 2016 1103 at age 94.
on acquisition the caplets were stored
inside a commercially available eight
dram Amber vial with a reversible cap
and a laser printed label in Comic Sans
which read migraine medicine e by dado
take one pill not two you trust dado the
only other medicines found were
over-the-counter painkillers at 15 new
plazid pima vanzarin 34 milligram
capsules in a bottle that indicated that
they had been prescribed to a local
acquaintance of Person of Interest
Clayton
starting at the age of 20 Rhonda Clayton
had acquired an extensive criminal
record with charges including fraud
racketeering and violation of the
Harrison narcotics tax act after being
released from prison in 1962 no further
negative interactions with the law
appeared on Clinton's public record not
even traffic violations starting in 2013
Clayton made a small name for herself in
the non-anomalous art scene in her home
state of Texas carving toothpicks into
miniature sculptures using dental tools
Clayton came to Foundation attention in
2014 when she started cultivating
friendships in the anomalous art scene
including an extensive male
correspondence with Person of Interest
in addition Foundation agents found the
following email correspondents on a
desktop PC in Person of Interest claims
bedroom evidence in conjunction with the
bottle's label that the scp-4193 caplets
had been produced by dado a person of
interest responsible for creating
anomalous pharmaceutical products and
anomalous businesses
this email thread will be presented as
an audio lock
playing log now
Hello darling a friend of mine tells me
you see I'm as healthy as a horse except
I have these terrible migraines just
awful normal medicines don't help me
much the doctors tell me I shouldn't
take too many painkillers they say that
makes it worse can you believe that does
that even make sense Dean can you help
me please
I make for you you trust dado I ship to
you in one week no charge I have ammos
on this crime
oh Mr dado are you all right I sometimes
pound on the keyboard like that when I
have a migraine it's like my eyes are
too big for my skull Sometimes I close
my eyes and push them and that does help
a little even though I'm not supposed to
do that I sometimes feel like if only
something could make my eyeball shrink
the pain would go away sorry hamster
walk on keyboard
I help you with I too oh you can help
with the pressure too I'm an ecstasy Mr
dado and it's reassuring to know you
have a pet
I can do it too I already make you get
them soon
Mr dado honey these are amazing I took
more than the pain and the pressure went
away instantly I'm going to tell all my
friends about you and your amazing Rook
please leave feedback on Amazon all my
friends don't pay attention to Amazon
hunt I'll do that but I'll give you some
Word of Mouth P.S the little Playboy
bunny is cute but I'm a little old for
that Mr Dado
God what do these pills do what did you
do to me you read label one pill not two
oh Mr dado you misunderstand I need to
take two on the same day it's been
months and months since I've had a
migraine but that never happens I'm so
impressed with your little blue pills oh
I was a little horrified when my eyes
shrank but then when I was able to work
on my toothpick art without a mattifying
glass even more detail Mr dado you are a
godsend you can wear my sunglasses when
I go out or when someone visits at my
age I can't afford vanity anyway it's
like you anticipated my needs I'm going
to recommend you to everyone yes no more
than two same day that's what they don't
meant please leave feedback on Amazon
Prime thanks holy I want to go
dancing
leaving all the feedback
additional email correspondence on the
desktop computer confirmed that person
of interest Clayton recommended Person
of Interest data to relatives and
acquaintances of her old criminal
contact and to her Associates in the art
scene Foundation analysis conclude that
person of interest Clayton's
recommendations are a contributory
factor in the request subsequently
received by Person of Interest data
and lock
Person of Interest Clayton died in a
head-on collision with a semi truck
after driving on the left side of the
I-35 Highway in her 2002 Honda Civic had
a speed of roughly 100 kilometers per
hour greatly attenuating the length of
her vehicle and pulverizing most of her
body including the skull when Person of
Interest Clayton's home in Austin Texas
was searched by the foundation in
addition to the desktop computer and
scp-4193 agents discovered a sculpture
different from Person of Interest
Clayton's usual work the sculpture is
nine feet tall vaguely humanoid with
bovine-like horns and made of
approximately 200 000 interlocking
toothpick carvings each of a maggot with
a smiling human face the sculpture had
attached a Post-It note photograph below
the Post-it note reads yes I am Dado
okay I think that about does it for
today
apologies for my voice today I'm kind of
sick but thank you for listening if
indeed you still are and you're all
dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to accept
zargara
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
disk lose Ray 420.
that loser
heroin sick
fire of prime
Indie versus the world
Spencer are doing
rubbish bin 69.
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
worthy fire
zazapan
lamke
segnor
ala Treon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
and Lyndon B Johnson
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you